ça au procès l'ours gros c'est le robot
master est sain de dj house est un robot
d'éducation en dessous sur le papier ou
gelée par emporter style et la journée
c'est une vidéo qui a réalisé en
partenariat avec dj hi maire s'est dit
jacques de m'avoir envoyé ce joli roman
je voulais justement le tester c'est
vraiment une super occasion j'ai déjà vu
lorsque je suis allé un salon autour de
l'éducation c'est le bête si en janvier
je crois que je suis allé en janvier
2019 déjà un petit moment
j'ai vu des robots autour de l'éducation
je suis très heureux que dj avait pu
sortir sa copie et puis sortir le sien à
mon avis et connaissant le travail et la
qualité de dj am ça va être une super
petite machine tout de suite je loue il
est là au nom de vie fest'arts intérieur
vous laisser quelques jours je le prends
en main je m'habitue ensuite je vous dis
exactement ce qu'il en est et émond a
dit effrayant
[Musique]
non
alors voyons voir un petit peu ce qu'il
ya à l'intérieur ce carton tac tac
qu'est ce qu'on a ici alors qu'est ce
qu'on voit effectivement au monastère on
a un petit schéma en fait il y en qui tu
es donc il faut le monter voilà là il
est complètement en kit il ya tout à
monter quand le boulot de ouf ça si vous
aimez montée des choses si vous êtes fan
de bricolage de modélisme et compagnie
je pense que là vous allez vraiment vous
éclater
ça c'est quand même énorme oh la vache
mais là vous êtes toute une partie du va
avec je pense les roues je connais pas
bien exactement mais je vois que c'est
énorme tout ce qu'on a à faire par soi
même
ça a l'air vraiment vraiment coup de
vous me laissez quelques jours le temps
de l'apprivoiser d'apprendre à le
connaître de le monter déjà c'est un
point très important je le monte je
regarde ça et ensuite vous expliquerai
comment ça marche ce qu'on peut
programmer g qui avait plein de choses à
faire
j'ai déjà mis ce type de produit en
terme de programmation je trouve ça
vraiment passionnant très ludique très
facile et à mon avis ça va être
sensiblement la même chose vous mais ces
quelques jours le temps de claquer des
mains et on se retrouve dans sion 1 2 ça
c'est vachement bien c'est vraiment
hypra cool regardez je les monte
il est là c'est un truc qui est vraiment
génial robot master et ça c'est comment
vous dire c'est un produit qui se
destine à tout âge j'ai eu le temps de
noter c'est de m'amuser de le voir un
peu tout le côté de le monter quand j'ai
vu ça j'ai vu la notice
j'ai pris peur faisaient du notice de
montage me suis dit mais je vais passer
dix jours des jours et des jours et des
jours entiers à monter de a à z et au
final pas du tout alors j'ai pas pris
des jours je crois que j'ai mis quelque
chose comme 3 heures pour tout monter
mais au début je me suis dit il ya tout
ça monte ça va être compliqué et au
final c'était vraiment sympa et c'est la
première étape
parce qu'en fait ce produit le robot
basterds et sans il se destine beaucoup
de personnes il se destine aux adultes
ils se destinent aux enfants il se
destine aux garçons ils se destinent aux
filles à toutes les personnes qui ont vu
une bricoler qui sont curieux qui sont
vraiment curieuse et qui ont envie
d'apprendre de comprendre tout en
s'amusant et c'est vraiment ça laden de
ce produit pourquoi parce que vous avez
un robot qui va allier le côté un petit
peu bricolage
déjà il faut le monter par semaine ça
vous montre comment ça marche vous
installer tout même jusque sur les roues
vous avez des petites des petits trucs
comme ça indépendamment vous
promenez vous et votre petit kit degré
savoir si vous mettez un petit point de
chaque côté vous montez quasiment tous
alors non parce que le la nacelle est
déjà monté le blaster il est déjà monté
il faut installer la petite caméra là
sur le devant avec deux vices vous venez
vis et s'avoue vie c'est tout vous allez
même faire ici la voyez vous à cette
petite partie avec les connectiques vous
avez vos petits câbles c'est vous qui
les tirait et vous les plugins alors il
vous explique tout vraiment à son bétail
et là dedans et une fois vous voulez
vous installez vous faites des tests
pour vérifier c'est tout a bien été
branché et s'il ya un problème et vous
le dira et vous reprenez vous y arrivez
vous verrez c'est très très simple tout
s'installe les cages vous montez les
capteurs ou bricoler tout de a à z
vous venez visiter tous les côtés je
sens vraiment beaucoup plus intéressant
dans ce sens là parce que au lieu de se
dire ok j'achète sa gelée comme ça je
vais monter maintenant y'a plus qu'à non
vous avez une première étape on est sur
un robot on va apprendre des choses donc
déjà vous apprenez à le monter au sens
fier on a une vraie récompense autant la
montée par semaine c'est le premier
point le deuxième point c'est
qu'effectivement c'est un robot ludique
parce qu'on peut s'amuser on peut soit
lancer des petites billes heures qui
vont s'éclater quoi pour écraser
notamment l'extérieur chez vous c'est un
peu plus compliqué vous risquez d'en
mettre partout mais sinon vous avez un
petit laser et vous allez tirer du laser
on le voit vraiment le laser donc
lorsque vous allez ajouter quelque chose
un autre robot quoi que ce soit et bien
ça se boit c'est vraiment hyper ludique
autant de bruit que vous montrez ça dans
quelques instants
donc on a un côté vraiment ludique vous
allez pouvoir faire du combat des
pouvoirs faire du suivi des pouvoirs à
avoir des arènes
mais ça c'est je dirais la partie
émergée de l'iceberg parce que ce robot
et vous permet d'apprendre le code de
façon très simple avec des blocs que
vous allez mettre sans vous rendre
compte que vous êtes en train
d'apprendre à coder vous allez codé et
façon extrêmement ludique et si vous
voulez aller plus loin vous mêmes le
code en python alors là il faut déjà
être un niveau plus avancé et vouloir
aller plus loin et comprendre mon jeu
tout con ça produit qui allie le côté
bricolage le côté physique le côté
programmation il ya aussi un côté un peu
matin il ya beaucoup de choses qu'on
pouvait faire avec je vous expliquais
j'ai tout vous montrer
et ça croyez moi c'est vraiment un
produit qui est vraiment top qui se
destine aux plus jeunes pas trop trop
jeune homme mon fils eliott à 6 ans il a
eu un peu de mal à comprendre alors rien
pour le côté un peu lui dis que je
prends je lui tire ça fait marrer mais
tout le côté par contre programmation on
est beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup trop
jeune mais je pense qu'un enfant voyez
verts 1,9 en dix ans il s'intéresse tout
ça si les curieux ça c'est un produit
qui est vraiment génial et même moi qui
fit beaucoup plus âgée que vous assurer
que ça vous vous éclatez voilà donc le
robot complètement fini de monter
regardez ça l'année
le truc ouf en fait ce qui est bien
c'est qu'il va pas juste se déplacer à
voir rien de pouvoir déplacer deux côtés
avec des mouvements deux roues qui sont
un petit peu complexe c'est vraiment là
parce que c'est hyper hyper hyper
intuitive vous en rendez pas compte
vous avez la caméra qui est planqué là
vous pouvez tirer ici vous avez tout
votre charge
ici la l'arrière au niveau des billes
que paul me retirer très facilement la
batterie cayla vous appuyez vous voyez
votre niveau de charge
elle se recharge très facilement grâce à
ça les cibles ça vous permet de créer
des parcours ça vous permet de vous
amuser ça vous permettra pas mal de
chance ça c'est vraiment cool
vous avez ce ruban là là vous allez
pouvoir faire des grandes lignes au sol
en france où d'autres programmations il
va suivre les lignes si vous plantez
vous le verrez vous corrigez vous
recommencez comprenait vraiment d'un
côté apprentissage ça sont des mini big
que vous mettez dans l'eau ça me permet
d'avoir les l'ebit pour venir shooter
alors attention parce que lorsque je
lourds y avait tellement de pression que
ça mon ami partout mais ça c'est toi
très très bien se ramasse très très bien
tout ça ce pilote bien sûr depuis une
application vous avez dans votre
smartphone c'est l'application robot
master ios android là je ne suis pas
connecté au robot la première chose
c'est d'allumer le robot en appuyant ici
on entend du bruit ici initialise ça
c'est une cible c'est notre beau via
shooter la paf sans réaction sur le mien
j'ai une cible la journée il là j'en ai
également unis si j'en ai la une faction
il faut que j'aille me connecter vous
qu'il ya d'autres collections pour se
connecter à votre bon goût avec deux
solutions soit vous connecter
directement en wifi vous directement au
robot vous professez de vous connecter
un routeur comme ça le routeur rayonnera
plus loin que votre propre smartphone
vous allez pouvoir couvrir une zone un
peu plus large mettre plusieurs robots
sur un routeur ça peut être rigolo
connexion réussie donc là-dessus
connecté à mon robot je vois mon niveau
de batterie l'âge est mort au bout donc
là j'ai plusieurs modes soit solo je me
déplaçais m'amuser faire comme je me
sens très très simple ces pratiques
au sam je me vois moi parce que j'ai le
robot qui est juste là voyez je peux
déplacer ma nacelle je suis vraiment en
phase dans le viseur donc là je me
shoote directement mois et
j'enregistrais déjà des petits messages
- elliott c'était
bon ça fait moi voilà donc je vous passe
le truc mais vous avez plein de
possibilités c'est franchement hyper
hyper hyper marrant à 100 pour les
petits messages donc là vous pouvez
tirer ici lire ici là vous déplacez le
robot d'un côté ou de l'autre
je suis vraiment garde parce qu'il est
posé sur la table je peux le faire
tomber la nacelle qu'il a pivoté mais
qui va également faire pivoter le robot
et vous allez pouvoir ensuite venir
filmer si vous le souhaitez ici en bas
donc là j'ai une carte microsd qui est
situé ici directement donc l'agent j
voyez comme ça je peux me portent
directement sur le robot si je le
souhaite ça fonctionne peut faire une
photo si je le souhaite
donc là je vous montre un petit peu le
côté un peu ludique tout en sachant que
vous allez pouvoir ensuite lorsqu'il est
programmée bien lui rajouter les
mouvements la partie cible donc là c'est
comme si vous étiez un sniper
vous voulez nous un peu plus mais sans
ma tête et j'ai eu je me tire dessus du
site vous avez une autre côté challenge
là c'est bien lorsque vous êtes quand
même à plusieurs robots vous allez
pouvoir faire des courses vous allez
pouvoir être dans une arène vous tirer
dessus il y avoir un mode conquête si
vous êtes très nombreux ces epr a coulé
après vous allez pouvoir en créer selon
ce que vous souhaitez bon là je vous
conseille quand même d'avoir plusieurs
rendez vous fait quand même se tiennent
mieux
oyez lie à moi vous pouvez rajouter
d'autres mais une fois de plus pour
jouer à ce mode là il faut être
plusieurs
et ce qui n'est pas mon cas personnel et
dans le côté lab c'est vraiment un côté
programmation et c'est pour moi aussi un
des points majeurs de ce robot parce
qu'il ya pour nous apprendre beaucoup de
choses
maîtriser votre robot dont vous allez
pouvoir avoir effectivement le guide
pour débutant qu'il est pouvoir vraiment
faire tout votre apprentissage
contrat-type mouvement directionnel
recherche destruction il ya beaucoup de
choses ensuite vous avez de la partie
programmation par bricolage ça c'est ce
qu'on appelle le scratch c'est par
exemple vous dites un jeu vous commencé
à programmer
vous allez dans nouveau vous avez votre
bloc commencé et là vous allez pouvoir
avoir plein de blocs d'actions et
pouvoir rajouter pour créer justement
des actions système définir le mode de
déplacement de mode à et vous allez
choisir comment il va se déplacer les
effets des led
le châssis la nacelle blaster
intelligence armure appareils mobiles
multimédias il ya beaucoup de choses
boisnier complètement tous programmés et
définir des séquences de mouvements
directement sur votre book par exemple
j'en sais rien mais on va se dire allez
le châssis régler le châssis pour qu'ils
suivent la nacelle attendre degré voyez
paf je le mets là je vais ensuite
définir un nombre de degrés montrent
vraiment un truc au pifomètre
mais on peut vraiment faire ce qu'on
veut et ensuite vous prenez tout le bloc
vous les imbriquer les uns aux autres et
lorsque c'est un millier je montre par
exemple j'arrive à une séquence qui
complexent vous pouvez vraiment le faire
faire beaucoup beaucoup de choses
elle est très loin mais
des conditions ça c'est toute la partie
de volley-ball scratch vous prenez vous
glissez vous déposez vous faites comme
vous voulez c'est vraiment très intuitif
et ça pour apprendre le code alors c'est
vraiment bien alors vous n'êtes pas
obligé d'aller sur des choses un petit
peu complexe tout de suite vous pouvez
aller sur des choses beaucoup plus
simples mais lorsque vous commencez à
comprendre et à maîtriser c'est génial
vous êtes l'issue relecture le mouvement
se fait une fois de plus le robot est en
hauteur je vais pas le faire je
montrerai retrait mais ça c'est vraiment
vraiment vraiment cool et on suit
lorsque vous roulez c'est vraiment le
scr alger dans le pit ont lancé la
version beta vous permet de comprendre
réellement comment ça se passe
réellement au niveau du col mais ça
croyez moi c'est vraiment génial parce
que ça c'est le code tel qu'il est en
réalité tel qu'il fonctionne non ça
permet vraiment de se mettre dedans
et lorsqu'on maîtrise déjà le scratch
vous allez jeter un petit coup d'oeil là
dedans et croyez moi c'est vraiment
génial
on a donc un robot qui à la fois
divertissant et à la fois éducatif vous
pouvez aller très très très loin en
terme de programmation si vous souhaitez
vous partez 2 0 vous connaissez pas
grand chose vous montez votre robot faut
commencer à vous amuser vous commencé à
programmer une première séquence et à
force d'en faire et à force d'en faire
et à force d'en faire des pouvoirs créé
des actions doit être vraiment complexe
réagir à certains types d'actions à
certains types d'interactions et
pourquoi pas au bout aller jusqu'à
comprendre le langage python et
comprendre comment fonctionne le code
est capable vous même de commencer à
coder sa première fac de modeler
l'esprit à comprendre comment ça marche
pas un côté ludique ça vous prend par la
main et ça vous apprend beaucoup de
choses sans que vous vous en rendiez
compte
ça parlait de connaître beaucoup de
choses reconnaissance des lignes que
vous allez faire au sol fera
connaissance des marqueurs au travers
des différentes s'il cible numérotée
différentes choses dont vous pouvez donc
faire des parcours plus ou moins
complexes vous avez aussi une
reconnaissance des personnes votent
robot peut me dire vous suivent dès lors
qu'il vous a reconnu pour les séquences
filmées pour plein d'autres choses c'est
vraiment bien
reconnaissance des applaudissements
lorsque vous allez à peu dire votre
europe est content faire la fête pour
les tous les côtés et sur ça il faut le
programme et par vous même avant
reconnaissance des gestes vous faites un
geste particulier le robot à faire une
action correspondante
et bien évidemment il reconnaître
d'autres robots est sain pour avoir
plein d'interaction avec laissez moi
prendre mon robot laissez-moi lemaitre
emballer ce mois vous montrer comment il
marche la vision qu'ils les déplacements
c'est incroyable j'étais habitué aux
voitures télécommandées
vous annoncez vous reculez différentes
directions là vous avancez tous les
côtés vous allez en crabe
on a des libertés mouvement de tous les
côtés que ce soit au niveau du blaster
soit les eaux du déplacement du robot va
être vraiment ce que vous voulez pour y
est juste la caméra je shoote
donc là vous voyez directement suite
maintenant je peux baisser la tête de
mon blaster hop je visais un peu plus
sur le bas tout en bas faut les viser
tout temps mais par contre je me
retournais extrêmement rapidement je
vais tourner directement c'est vraiment
hypra il prend il pas facile je vois la
caméra je shoote et là hop je le tourne
si jme dernière je vais tout et je monte
je me vois moi je me soutenant une fois
de plus le mec les commandes vocales
[Musique]
vous faites vraiment ce que vous voulez
y voyez les déplacements qui sont
complètement fous là encore je tue
qu'avec le blaster donc là je fais
vraiment que le tourner en fonction de
ce que voit mon blaster là où il veut
aller et lorsque je vois ce que les
bases et son côté j'ai ma petite molette
up à l'avant à l'arrière
je leur fais vraiment ce que je veux il
se déplace en crabe dans tous les sens
et lorsque j'allais en plus avec la tête
du blaster je fais des choses qui sont
vraiment cons partout surtout waouh ça
réagit très très très vite
hop hop je veux ajouter rafale je vivais
hop je tourne je me suis moi je retourne
vers la caméra café caméra je fais
vraiment ce que je veux comme je veux
regarder le mouvement des roues là je
suis vraiment que sur la rotation de la
nacelle
c'est impressionnant la nacelle comme
halde va comme elle bouge les roues
comme elle tourne c'est extrêmement
réactifs par exemple on peut se faire
une démo seule chose qui est déjà
programmé toute une séquence jeu mes
lectures et le rambo voyez agit
directement en fonction qui était
programmé on va s'en faire une autre
vous avez cette séquence de
programmation lecture
et vous avez même une sur la séquence
d'attac et elle tire si bleu ainsi bleus
2 vous avez pas mal d'options si
directement sans votre robot toute la
partie connexion directement ici en wifi
la partie affichage ou même changer les
couleurs des leds voyez la led elle est
comme ça vous la voyez en dessous de la
passer en rouge si je souhaite en
fonction de ce que j'ai envie de faire
je peux choisir la résolution de la
vidéo soit le mode de tir avec les
faisceaux soit avec les bills de gênes
le type de contrôle avec un smartphone
avec une manette avec un pc et pas mal
de possibilités dans le système donc ça
aussi c'est vraiment bien si vous êtes
calcul curieux et que vous avez vraiment
envie de vous amuser et d'apprendre sans
vous en rendre compte pour moi ça c'est
vraiment petit bijou c'est un excellent
produit
moi je suis tombé amoureux j'adore mes
cadres vraiment avec sartre côté ludique
vous comprenez comment s'articule le
code commentcamarche façon extrêmement
simple et sympa qui coûte 5 149 euros
d'ailleurs si vous intéresse vous aimez
un lien en bas dans la description
j'adore schultz a vraiment bien fait et
on a vraiment une sensation de
robustesse c'est fou parce qu'on dit ok
je le monte et moi même est ce que au
final avec les chocs qui risque de
prendre
est ce qu'il va être résistant puisque
vous assurez la il pèse son poids croyez
moi c'est ça sert aussi d'alter break ça
me fait aussi mon sport la journée il
est robuste se trouve vraiment bien leur
éviter le dans les escaliers je ne peux
pas tout garantir non plus mais sur une
tenue au sol il est vraiment cool un peu
passe partout
c'est vraiment un très joli produit je
vous dis une fois de plus pour côté
divertissement et éducation en même
temps qu'il est vraiment bien et ce qui
est super avec ce produit c'est que
chacun va venir piocher ce qui
l'intéresse sur le que le divertissement
et bien on peut voir que le
divertissement déjà recruté vous
vraiment super bien pour avoir
uniquement du divertissement
si vous voulez en plus aller un peu plus
loin et apprendre le code et pourquoi
pas tout de suite mais peut-être plus
tard eh bien vous pourrez le faire je
dirais que le seul bémol avec ce produit
c'est que si vous voulez l'utiliser pour
faire de la reine ou du combat eh bien
il faut des amis qui en est un et à ce
moment là il faut des amis qui
investissent parce que c'est quand même
un produit qui coûte 5 149 euros
ça me paraît pas de déconner vu ce qu'on
allait enfin de techno mais ça reste
quand même malgré tout un certain budget
dit pas ce que vous en pensez
est ce que ça pourrait vous tentez ou de
programmer et de vous amuser que ce
petit produit là je trouve vraiment cool
il ya toujours une belle maîtrise de la
part de dj hi au niveau de ses nacelles
au niveau de sa stabilisation au niveau
des innovations
c'est un produit que je trouve vraiment
très très beau et super intéressant on
va me dire ce que vous en pensez en bar
commentaire quant à nous on se retrouve
très rapidement pour continuer par
l'etec nous en être à bientôt trois mois